dans ce qui semble être une cave
souterraine non loin de la ligne de
front le président en r hommage à ses
soldats c'est un grand honneur de vous
rencontrer ici
aujourd'hui de vous
soutenir et de vous récompenser les
gars je veux que vous
soyez
cette visite a lieu dans le village de
robotine repris l'été dernier lors de la
contreoffensive ukrainienne contre les
forces russes une commune de la région
de zaporidja dont la reconquête a été
saluée comme un succès majeur mais
depuis cette contreoffensive s'est
progressivement arrêté et robotine est
devenue la cible d'attaque incessante de
l'armée russe des attaques auxquelles
les troupes ukrainiennes ripost samedi
un bombardement ukrainien a touché une
boulangerie dans la ville
au moin 28 personnes aur perdu la vie
selon les autorités
Prusses j'ai entendu des cris et quelque
chose m'a frappé dans le dos je me suis
retourné mais j'éta sous les décombres
beaucoup de gens on crié à l'aide grâce
au sauveteur et à la police militaire
qui était sur place j'ai été
sauvé Kief n'a pas commenté la frappe
mais soldats russes comme ukrainiens ont
régulièrement recours à des tirs longues
porté pour affaiblir l'autre sans grand
succès les positions sont resté
largement inchangé au cours des derniers
mois